en la sala de urgencias psiquiátricas de
clermont
este hombre de 66 años llegó por la
noche
y macro va a decir
que vaya por el sol y la luna
qué quiere que hagamos con el sol y la
luna hay muchas ideas en la cabeza se
mezclan la doctora jeunesse salenses la
jefa del servicio de urgencias
psiquiátricas del hospital universitario
de clermont ferrand con su equipo revisa
los casos de los nuevos pacientes
mientras tanto el hombre es colocado en
un cubículo de aislamiento parece que
nos fue bien con el aislamiento
está muy angustiado e incoherente pero
no es agresivo a menudo tenemos
situaciones más complejas que requieren
más tiempo porque se suman al
aislamiento social a las interrupciones
en la atención en parte por el joven en
los últimos años ha habido una
precarización de los pacientes
psiquiátricos y esto va en aumento con
el cob y sin lugar a dudas
al final de la reunión la doctora vuelve
con su paciente
todavía aislado
como esta le quitó todo eso lo sentimos
pero antes se habría hecho daño si no lo
hubiéramos contenido
[Música]
me alegra ver que el tratamiento lo ha
calmado un poco desde hace varias
semanas el hombre hace declaraciones
incoherentes los vecinos alertaron a los
paramédicos esta es una historia que
comenzó en el primer confinamiento
cuidad está tomando lo pasó muy mal con
la privación de libertad no y tendría
todas esas normas son claras poco de
felicidad para ese trabajo probablemente
tenía un fondo ansioso-depresivo aunque
nunca tuvo problemas psiquiátricos más
significativos
es difícil encontrar camas para todos
los pacientes en este otro edificio del
hospital esta unidad tiene capacidad
para 25 adultos hola
estoy aquí para tomarle la atención como
este hombre hospitalizado tras una
sobredosis de metadona es complicado el
toque de queda a los restaurantes
cerrados los bares todo eso lo que me
gustaría es que todo volviera a la
normalidad y poder regresar a casa lo
antes posible
además de la falta de camas los
cuidadores se quejan de que las
instalaciones son antiguas y no están
adaptadas a la situación sanitaria no
tenemos habitaciones de dos camas así
que es complicado el distanciamiento
social eso creo que lo más complicado
para nosotros es pasión y para ellos
hemos tenido problemas durante mucho
tiempo sea lo que sea estamos aquí para
los pacientes y luego hacemos lo mejor
que podemos
es en instalaciones como esta a las que
se remiten algunos pacientes recibidos
en urgencias psiquiátricas
en la región de parís el centro
hospitalario teófilo jus el acoge a
adultos y adolescentes
para estadías hasta de varios meses
huesca y noveno
hoy tres jóvenes participan en un taller
de teatro parece un cerdo aplastado en
la carretera tal vez sea una estatua de
pig debemos llamar a la policía en
absoluto
que eras
algo muerto momificado
para estos adolescentes la crisis
sanitaria fue difícil de sobrellevar
para mí no debería haber sido complicado
porque no tenía más vínculos sociales
pero en enero encontré algunas personas
y nos hicimos muy amigos
el único problema fue que nos confiaron
justo después y fue muy duro
no fue agradable me sentí nervioso
ansioso
póngase
tenía miedo de que mi familia se
contagiará del coronavirus
el uso con
mi hermano pequeño tiene una enfermedad
pulmonar y tenía miedo de transmitírselo
a menudo se culpa a los adolescentes de
transmitir el virus para la doctora back
beyond huevos esta estigmatización causa
mucho sufrimiento durante los últimos
dos meses más o menos ha habido una ola
psiquiátrica
se trata de adolescentes que no
necesariamente conocíamos que no habían
consultado ni en la práctica privada ni
en nuestras consultas
pero que recurren a actos suicidas oa la
autoflagelación y que por tanto acuden a
urgencias en momentos de intensa
desesperación
en el sector de la atención a los
adultos este taller de jardinería
terapéutica pudo reanudarse después de
haber sido interrumpido al principio del
primer confinamiento nos saca de la
enfermedad y nos devuelve a la tierra
los confinamientos le están causando una
tremenda ansiedad a todo el mundo
a todo el mundo personas que tenían una
vulnerabilidad compensada por una vida
normal ahora se encuentran vulnerables y
pueden manifestar síntomas e incluso
desarrollar trastornos me preocuparía
más por la población en general que por
los pacientes
se ocupan de ellos tienen el seguimiento
de los equipos en su mayor parte
temen que la crisis psiquiátrica sea
mucho más larga que la sanitaria